Okay, so today I'm going to talk about a first-in-class anti-CD94 antibody. DR01 was
the previous name, and recently we got a new name, Dibodatug, and this is in relapsed refractory
cytotoxic lymphomas. So cytotoxic NK and T-cell lymphomas are a rare group of malignancies,
and they have a high admit need. In non-Hodgkin lymphoma, they make up less than 15% of all
non-Hodgkin lymphomas. These cytotoxic lymphoma entities, and these include extranodal NK T-cell
lymphoma, the intestinal lymphomas, hepatosplenic T-cell lymphomas, subcutaneous paniculitis-like
T-cell lymphoma, or primary cutaneous gamma-delta T-cell lymphoma, they are characterized by a
cytotoxic phenotype and commonly expressed CD94. These patients have very poor prognosis,
and there is really no standard of care treatment approach for these
patients. The median overall survival is generally less than one year from diagnosis,
and this highlights a significant unmet medical need.
So Dibodatug, or DR01, is a non-fucosylated IgG antibody that is expressed on terminal
effector CD8-positive T-subsets and NK cells. So you can see here on the left, CD94 expression
is minimal to absent on naive.
And a memory subsets, but it's quite high in terminal effector and natural killer populations,
and that provides for a degree of biologic selectivity. Dibodatug engages the FC gamma
receptors, such as CD16A, and triggers ADCC, and this results in rapid depletion of CD94 expression
from terminal effector cells. So this is a first in human open-label phase 1-2,
study looking at the safety and preliminary efficacy of Dibodatug in relapsed refractory
cytotoxic T-cell lymphomas. There was several phases to this study. Essentially, the part A
was dose escalation, and the doses ranged anywhere from 0.3 milligrams per kilogram up to 10 milligrams
per kilogram with both CTL, so cytotoxic T-lymphomas, and LGLL patients treated at those
doses. Part B was dose escalation, and the doses ranged anywhere from 0.3 milligrams per kilogram up to 10 milligrams per kilogram with both CTL, so cytotoxic T-lymphomas, and LGLL patients treated at those doses.
Part B was dose escalation, and the doses ranged anywhere from 0.3 milligrams per kilogram up to 10 milligrams per kilogram with both CTL, so cytotoxic T-lymphomas, and LGLL patients treated at those doses.
Part B was just dose optimization and dose expansion, and there we actually see we have
separate cohorts for the CTL and the LGLL populations. The optimal dose for the CTL
patients have been determined, and it was determined to be 1 milligram per kilogram.
There's been several induction regimens that are still being looked at for these patients,
but overall, the induction is during the first month. After that, it's just once every
four weeks, so here we see the baseline demographics. The median age is 53 years.
Most of the patients were non-Hispanic whites. To date, the most common histology that is
represented here include extranodal NKT cell lymphoma at 24% and primocutaneous gamma-delta
T cell lymphoma at 20%. Number of prior lines of therapy was 3. 41% of patients were refractory
to their prior therapy, and 16% of patients had prior stem cell transplant.
Here is the AE table, and slide of the 81 cytotoxic T cell lymphoma patients who were
treated. Infusion-related reactions was the most common treatment-related AE. The majority were
low-grade, and all events were manageable with mitigation of the standard monoclonal
antibody strategies that we use, such as pre-medication, splitting the initial dose over
two days, etc. There were five cases of viral infections or reactivations noted as well. They
were as well all low-grade, and they all result as expected, and there were no treatment-related deaths
observed. So here we see efficacy of the Bota tug and overall response rates 53%, CR rate 30%, and
a CR rate of 60%. We can see the POTUS-Plenic T cell lymphoma with an overall response rate of 75%
and a CR rate of 50%, SPT-CL an overall response rate of 80%, and a CR rate of 60%. I mean,
I think we all know these are diseases that, generally, if you have them,
it's essentially equivalent to a death sentence for a majority of our patients. Here we see the
SWIM-LANE T cell lymphoma with an overall response rate of 75% and a CR rate of 80%.
Here we see the SWIM-LANE T cell lymphoma with an overall response rate of 80%. Here we see the
SWIM-LANE T cell lymphoma with an overall response rate of 75% and a CR rate of 80%. Here we see the
patients who received the one milligram per kilogram dose, and we are seeing durable responses. The
median duration of response is 9.9 months, and the longest duration on treatment to date is 27 months
and is ongoing. So, biomarker analysis showed that CD94 expression was found on 95% of the baseline
tumor samples, but the clinical responses were observed on 95% of the baseline tumor samples, but
the clinical responses were observed on 95% of the baseline tumor samples, but the clinical responses
were observed on 95% of the baseline tumor samples, but the clinical responses were observed independent
of baseline CD94 expression level, and the CD94 positive cells were depleted with Dabotatug.
So, to conclude, Dabotatug continues to demonstrate promising safety and efficacy,
supporting its development as a treatment option in cytotoxic T cell lymphomas. In terms of safety,
infusion-related reactions was really the most common. Treatment-related AE usually occurred during
the first dose and was manageable with standard mitigation strategies. Overall response rates
were very promising, 53%, and there were a high proportion of CRs across multiple histologies as
well. The responses were durable with a median duration of response of close to 10 months.
CD94 expression was near universal across all these samples, but, you know, when we
did the analysis, patients did benefit from Dabotatug regardless of their baseline CD94
expression level. This study is currently ongoing. There is a phase two, and it's enrolling CTL
patients globally. And these are all the sites that are involved and all the investigators, so
thank you everybody.